trophy that you go on the bridge to country model
decolonization will now really begin
and thus ends the power of america
and a petro dolle
has now become known
that three of the largest oil producing countries iran
saudi arabia and the united arab emirates
going to join the bricks community
the british community
known to want to get rid of the dollar
as a world trading funk
and prefer to trade in your own currencies
what is would mean
like these oil-producing countries
going to sell their oil
outside the dollar
because there is much less demand for dollars
and America's economy is likely to collapse
although let the British community know
that this is not a goal to the american
dollar completely
that they want a collaboration sooner
in which they are sustainable
create a fair and diverse world
with multiple trading coins outside the dollar
on the guiding arts pose standards
criterion and positions
of the bix expansion process
Which has bean intistation for guideline
We have consensus
On the first face of this expansion process
And are the face is where follow
We have the sides to invite
The argent republic
The kingdom of saudi arabia
And the united ever emerites
To become full members of Bridge
The membership will take effect from
The first of jenna wherey 2021